Okay, why is machine learning useful? So that's, that, that's
a great question and, and it, you know, I, I think
it touches on this, this sort of classic question, or
this long running discussion, on what is the difference between statistics
and machine learning. there's, there, there's a lot of great
papers. There's one classic paper, I, I forget the name exactly,
but it's something along the lines of the two cultures, and
talking about why these two different approaches developed. So I think,
if you look at machine learning, it, it grew out
more of a computer science direction, and, and it grew
out of a lot of areas where people had very
practical hands on questions, right? How can we build the
best recommendation system? How can we make the best predictions
or classifiers for, for a given problem? And machine learning
has developed a lot of really, really good techniques for
doing that, for doing things that work very well in practice.
And so I, I think that's there, there are
a lot of applications where that's really what you're
getting at particularly when you have the opportunity to
build a product that will you know, take some action
based on, based on some algorithms. Those are areas
where machine learning is really at the cutting edge
of coming up with the most effective ways of
making decisions in real time based on data. I see.